you get around Syria Israel access so
the thing is easy going to be able to
give life to the dead now I was an
escutcheon with a Christian and I was
trying to make a point because he was
saying or Islam is the Antichrist
[Music]
by any so high level feed the power
[Music]
before the video starts guys check out
sponsors and natures blend they
specialize in premium Ethiopian black
seed products their products are
fantastic health supplements and also
from the Sun now the website is in the
description link below you can also use
the discount code Salam 10 for 10% of
their products what are you guys waiting
for
dear friends hope you guys are well
inshallah welcome to this unnamed show
that we have no name to it but we
discuss a variety of topics
welcome to studios so guys now yes I was
on live and I was doing some fundraising
on orphanage that was gonna be built
handle in love we reached nearly fifty
thousand pounds may Allah bless every
single one of you guys now as I was on
that life thing on Instagram have you
seen also what are you guys talking
about so I had a glimpse at it what
we're going to react to it I'm going to
react with Shamu Sofia well I'm gonna
react to it and because obviously
there's some elements of I mean I will
cover them up females obviously amongst
around our teachers you know we should
be respectful and I'm sure they would
not want to see that which I'm very
highly doubt they don't want to and
that's the reason why he's gonna come on
straight after we react to I'm gonna get
a few points where we're gonna comfort
it from an element of the hadith Islamic
literature what do you say about it and
let's see blogging seems been very
strange what do we know about it he's
leading desperate people so this is a
cult we don't know who he's associated
with he could be creating an army okay
yeah he can be creating an army okay or
he could be leading them to their death
okay interesting interesting words their
phrases and it's quite interesting that
a lot of people are like staring there's
like a big gathering and when the chef
comes Ian shot laughter we've washed it
we're going I'm talking about what kind
of people are going to be following
what were you doing in Syria
Oh everywhere not France not London not
Hong Kong Syria
[Music]
okay so there's a massive storm going on
tornado and he's the only one that's
standing there so he's showing something
supernatural yeah I will assume is maybe
Superman's cousin
that's a Korean okay he's your father to
me that sounds more like you know
because
[Music]
[Music]
that is key
he's saving lives yeah it's very key cuz
that's certain at least I've seen but
let's let's carry on so he's saving
lives miracle supernatural staff who's
your father doesn't answer its can
simply be the Messiah he's gonna he's
gonna be in Syria there's okay let's see
it looks like it was a maybe a strict
Salafi brother this is very key remember
these things he gets in your game around
fast yeah there's her visa bus okay this
is this is some shear key biblical Jesus
type thing going oh so it's a guy
kneeling kissing his hand yeah
and he's claiming it to be God's work
[Music]
Second Coming did he say second comment
I heard that so we we know we believe
the Christians was a belief of the
second coming of Chania
[Music]
phone Scott did you guys see that did
you guys see that folks good
all right so basically sure obviously
you heard this is a new Netflix series
sort of program that's coming yet it's
quite interesting that we don't know if
they're trying to depict you know it's
lighting it because Miss effect yes so
described as the famous one was common
amongst two people is that one of his
eyes will be deformed yes yes actually
uncommon that most people don't know and
this is the pin of kadhi in fact this
the other narrations suggest both of his
eyes the right and the left would be
both deformed so one will be deformed
that won't be be bulging deform the
center form and process you know because
this generation as a bulging eye or
something that is just like okay that's
the thing because obviously we know that
they'll be cut as well between this
thing similar here is going to be
something described it as well the thing
is is that we can see with this is that
they are like normalizing the jab
because the gel is someone quite
repulsive and quite ugly in appearance
yeah his actions will come to that shole
a bit in terms of his appearance he's
someone quite repulsive that also Muslim
also mentioned but you can see her that
they're trying to make someone that is
even trying to make something as
repulsive appealing and trying to
normalize the concept of that so really
it lives up to kind of the judge being
the judge and the journal comes from the
word digit which means Kenneth and I
okay so it's it's quite strange yeah
because the thing that I think they're
trying to depict this person as Esau
Nissan the Messiah yeah isn't Messiah
the chosen one so let me see it refers
to riesen yeah yeah let me see what the
gel is the imposter who would appear as
Monsieur okay cuz here it's a bit
confusing like if this journey isn't
funny fine if I'm God is not blue eyed
and blond-haired
more chillin you know the Eastern why he
looks like now there's some things you
should wear I'm thinking
so these guys read the hadith because
it's profound because they're talking
about statements massive following yeah
what kind of following the job going to
have probably known many a hadith
abyssal awesome destructive jealous
having a large following comprised of
meaning Arab oh and woman as well no
females a lot of females to the extent
that describe that men would actually
like tie their wife's then tied it like
daughters to the house to prevent them
from going out so they'll be allowed to
him you'll be something that someone
that is quite charismatic someone that
has a [ __ ] to him okay so okay that's
that's another thing and a lot of people
will be following him a lot of people
suddenly want another hadith over
seventy thousand yahood they'll come out
from us by hand I must behind it's like
more than eight you're on another hadith
called a Sun region which is modern-day
Iran I know him too well yeah it's a he
said the greatest ever MBA the prophets
weren't there their followers people who
would go out trying to kind of challenge
him but they'll fall for yes they were
his trap absolutely so it's best to run
away absolutely no you run away but
protect yourself and how do you protect
yourself
number one he man number one your good
deeds number three reciting the the
first ten or memorized in the first 10
on the last ten verses and sort of stuff
and in that in fact is a beautiful thing
because sort of CAF talks about it talks
about a story of of of the people the
people of the cave it talks about the
story of Musa with a good it talks about
the people in little quarantine and yeah
dramatic and it talks about how the
sadena manner who are literally the
people who beat at lost the most
basically the absolute losers in this
life and the next are the ones that
literally you know don't believe and you
know
who have deceived themselves into doing
good but in reality they do but so it's
connected to the Dodger and what he
would do so here you can see the horse
I'm gonna I'm gonna ask you to look at
the screen once ourselves quotes and
just simply don't see anything
inappropriate so here as you can see
this is fine you can look so this is he
he's standing there okay and there's
like a storm going on yet like and
people are wonderful it's not the rappin
he's just there so we can define this
stop some kind of a miracle know what is
some of the miracles that he's gonna
come up with because like we know
there's gonna be and one thing I found
really interesting is that I think
there's a boy boy there yeah yeah I'm
sorry I said a boy how many job boy but
here there's a little kid and he reminds
me of a child is gonna boy that's gonna
come to him and he's going to say that
you are at that jar yeah and he's gonna
slice him in half
yes and bring him back to life and then
the boy will have even more so I'm more
sure that you are told us about I
thought the jail tried to kill him again
but he wouldn't be able to
oh really yeah so this is a young boy a
shed Wow
and also the gels that should be
described with someone who's a chef
himself what someone who's a chef
someone who's a young person as well
okay so I think definitely the makers of
this they've done the research
yeah and they've definitely kind of
probably read the hadith yeah so the
thing is easy going to be able to give
life to the dead this was me describe to
me oh really
yeah you see what this guy says in the
thing is that go see he saved my
daughter's life yes so it's a great test
it's a great test whole line and it's a
very very scary test alone yeah so we
also got lots of predictors from because
that's one of the thing in it we make
about Allah protect us from the
punishment of the grave but it was wrong
the Hellfire
protect us off the bet in it yeah many
hadith actually see it which you know we
saw some of them to see groceries okay
sure you know I was having a discussion
with a Christian okay in fact so there's
gonna be a lot of thing because over
here we have let me see if I can find it
there we go okay so you can a Volusia so
false code yeah
okay so now this is interesting here
because once I had cuz the Christians
believe in Antichrist yeah now I was an
expression with a Christian I was trying
to make a point because he was seeing
Islam is the Antichrist yeah enough okay
look you know you're making a claim you
know substantiate it but I said argument
see okay let's call with this yes now
for spot here claim that this clearly
shows to me that he's one of the two
he's either being depicted as easily
surround yeah or the dajjal yeah so he's
either coming to fight the doctor or he
himself is the doctor yeah now I was
thinking him ask you know you gotta be
coming to fight that at least Alex and
I'm just going to come no but see and he
said no Miriam yeah would descend
what was the Gerald is already prison oh
yeah of course gonna come and before the
the Matthew be present and Bernie this
one hadith suggests that you know in
recent money would descend in Damascus
and he'll go to lead the salons l'm
sorry they would then appoint him to
lead salah and he said i need to cut the
income Amira come let your emir lead the
prayer another ratio and Maddie need the
person we know that Maddie would be
present when Marie comes down so you
could say the chronology the chronology
of the events it seems to be in Allah
knows best the gel ISA an interesting up
after that huge yeah and then so on and
so forth so some say that my tea is my
family deciding someone side oh and the
first of the major son sister jet well
and the rest will follow like a beats
falling okay so what was seems but he's
gonna come and fight okay so interesting
cuz he will fight him but I heard the
name Philistine Oh Israel it's
interesting because and it was Miriam he
would send in Damascus okay
but then he in Syria yes see he comes
yeah but then he will start pursued the
journal and who meet him I please Cober
blood which is next to Bethlehem
Palestine and he'll kill him
so go from Syria Palestine and it's
interesting he didn't mention that he's
going to go to Saudi Arabia
able to get in there no no but he will
not get into Medina okay so why was he
into this Christian valve which I was
coming back to him was that he says it's
with Antichrist yeah and I say to him
like because I was reading some passages
in the Bible I was seeing - hold on a
second I said Antichrist gonna come okay
Antichrist coming to miracles he said
yes yeah I sense Christ gonna be a man
you said yes I said and Christ is gonna
probably laughter dead you said yes I
said which religion believes that God
comes down as a man gives life to the
dead is divine yeah I would do miracles
yeah yeah and he why is it many exactly
exactly but the point here is this that
for you to call us Antichrist you know
the problem is you are more likely to
fall for it because you believe it and
we know the process of selling toward a
start your Lord is not - is not one
night now yeah so we can learn from that
that yeah sure back I said before I was
telling him but you more likely to
follow him because it forced your
criteria of our bodies we don't believe
God is a man yeah so if it comes to us
in college were among the movements
strong believers we will deny and say
look you know our Lord because we don't
believe our Lord can come down you are
more prone to fall for it yeah because
you've already fell for it once you lost
in so how is even be under our being a
yeoman or super super and you be for 40
days 40 days hadith is one day will be
like you year the second day will be
like your month and the third day will
be like the rest of your society and
call up the rest of two days a week and
then these yeah okay okay one of the
interesting test is going to do the
judge terms about yes
scribing that he will come with the
Jinnah and enough who come with like a
garden yeah and fire
I did another hadith water and fire and
his Jenna of his garden will be fire and
his fire whooping God and he used this
to come vegetation was brought forth
from the earth and even the people to
show that he has some kind of booby o
divinity and control oh one second he's
gonna be would you mean garden God some
other in a mansion that it's a sign that
he'll be able to learn wherever he goes
vegetation and you put fire and oh I
thought you meant therefore was
discussing that he would say jump into
the fire it would be Jenna no that's not
what you seen you said he would have
powers of making a guardian you have
certain it'll claim to be a certain
claim to but you know give vegetation
forth and you know and in another hadith
loop you don't have a mountain of bread
and stuff obviously it's a kinda it
means that you'll comes a lot of
provisions but basically me Allah Allah
protect us I think it's important that
we mentioned the promise this is hard to
picture so how do you deal SS - so we've
talked about the problem you know and
one of the signs that that the jar would
come is that when they start talking
about me the members well there's some
but I mean look number one maybe some
water Celebi longest Allah told us about
sort of sort of emphasized so I
mentioned it before some Hadees just the
first ten verses some had uses the
previous ten verses to memorize it to
them an oasis the one who's the butt of
it so it's not just memorizing but
contemplation so sort of the calf is key
here sort of calf is key cause I
mentioned what sort of calf talks about
but also I told the end so no calf talks
about a resurrection it talks about the
final day yeah
it talks it has very so it has these
kind of key elements so when do you
recite that is there a specific time or
a day yes but in general if the fit of
the gel comes then one should recite
this it's been like you know sort of
MOOC is when a media knows I'm a
potential punishment the grave yeah
oh yeah beautifying Buddha's repose in
citizens yes you've seen it I think it's
very important for you guys to
understand that you know that this is
some people think oh it's just the joke
etc the fact that they've made it so
accurate in those context of talking
about certain things when when they said
all your traveling from Syria City Star
and that's one of his side that he's
gonna be traveling places fast being
away is weird cuz annoy it causes
actually more swings to read about the
dress it's really about our feed off the
journey yeah so in a way it's actually
educate the Muslims specific attributes
for specific beautiful sisters as you
can see this life is temporary and
believe me we're gonna have we're gonna
have trials we all do we all have all
tests own tests that we go for inshallah
but this is a test not to be messed
around with it not to be joked around
with let's see what happens I don't know
I don't know each other and share this
video with maybe your Muslim friends and
maybe they can look into because they've
got you think they've read I was just
you know I don't know that's what scene
maybe there's a Muslim or those guy
behind to make some sisters a ceremony
home